they really don't need any introduction
but I'll introduce them in any case
briefly Anna Kendrick's singing up a
storm as Cinderella Rob Marshall
directing to a furious and remarkable
fare-thee-well the director James Corden
who knew he sang in addition to
everything else as the Baker and John De
Luca producer so thank you all for being
with us John I guess as the producer
it begins with you possibly without the
money it wouldn't happen maybe you could
just tell us what actually got this
going there had been several false
starts before where we thought we were
going to have a movie into the woods and
we didn't why did it happen now well
they really started with Rob and myself
we we both had seen the show in 87 and
as we do our projects together we always
have a dialogue as to what will be next
what we're thinking of and as you know
musicals are near and dear to our hearts
and into the woods came up at one point
and as we investigated it we really we
just thought this could this could work
we could we could make this a film then
we brought it to Disney and they were on
board and and we dove in it was really
just our discussions and you know we
have long lists of ideas that we have
and into the was rose to the top and and
the more we the more we sought
cinematically the more we thought we
could we could attack it and and bring
it about did it matter John what had
been done previously or did you just
want the slate clean well we did read
the other script there was one script
that we did read and it was just it was
in such a different direction that we
just we just started anew mm-hmm
when with it with the original writer
james lepine and knew that we wanted to
honor the original production as much as
we could and then of course Rob you had
the fantastic an enviable task of having
to cast it a wonderfully eclectic house
drawing from theater people a Tony
winner a Tony nominee and of course film
stars how did you think about getting
that film theater balance right for
casting of the film version of a Tony
winning musical it happened kind of
actually naturally in Oh
um you know I have this sort of
philosophy got casting and that is that
you don't have to if you do it right you
don't have to make any decisions at all
it's they're made for you you know when
we did a reading of the piece two years
ago and these two lovely people actually
were in the reading which was fortuitous
and you know it was in that moment that
both James and Anne it was clear that
this was they were meant for these roles
you know I love when actors say this is
mine and and that's what I mean
James came in I didn't I mean I knew his
work on stage I knew he's a brilliant
comedian and but I had no idea no idea
that he had this amazing voice and also
had such depth and vulnerability as an
actor and and sort of could sing and I
mean the the range was his range is
pretty extraordinary and it was obvious
to me right then and there that that
this is the Baker he claimed role and
said it's mine and same with Anna and I
brought such an inch and this is what
they bring in the film too but Anna
brings such such depth such
vulnerability such complexity to this
role in addition to her humor and sort
of a modern sensibility which I love
about her and this extraordinary voice
it was it was sort of like this is mine
and so that's what I always hope can
happen you know musicals are still few
and far between so you have to do a
little bit of detective work as you're
trying to figure out who can do this
kind of thing I didn't know Emily Blunt
could sing I didn't know Chris Pine
could sing
I knew Meryl Streep could sing but I
didn't know she could sing like this and
that was that was a huge surprise to see
that happen did Rob Stephen Sondheim who
is famously protective and rightly so of
his work did he take a lot of persuading
given that there been some false starts
before no you know James as soon as we
decided we wanted to do it I call James
Lepine I asked him to write the
screenplay and ask Steve to come on
board and help us as we maneuvered our
way you know it's very delicate taking
something from stage to film because you
really want to honor the original but
you must serve it as a film as well and
they were incredibly flexible
I'm incredibly flexible about it because
they'd written it you know they said
well we can rewrite this or retain do
this they still saw it as a living
breathing thing
there wasn't that protection that you
think there might be it was actually the
opposite I actually found myself saying
we can't touch that don't touch that
that's you know we don't want to move
that around but you know you you have to
be very aware of the fact that it's a
film I mean for me on stages I don't was
it close to two hours and 45 minutes on
stage something like that
and you know and film musicals can't
really sustain that kind of length I
mean I feel like almost the length we
are is really where it needs to be I
can't imagine it 10 more minutes 15
minutes even longer so we're we were all
very aware of that and aware that we
needed to condense and adjust and make
things work for film that are you know
there are staged conventions that don't
work on filming you have to be smart
about that James in your extraordinary
performance on stage and one man to
governor's which I had the pleasure of
seeing four times you did almost
everything except sing were you amazed
to find yourself singing on screen
especially the work of Stephen Sondheim
uh in a word yes you know I think I it
was it was a little easier in one sense
because when I went to audition when I
went to audition for Rob and John
I wasn't auditioning for a huge movie
starring Meryl Streep like I was
auditioning for a workshop for a movie
that would if it got made style Meryl
Streep and if it does get made it
probably won't star you do you not mean
like that's that's sort of and so I
think I felt it was it was a little
easier in a sense but I I remember I
remember it so vividly every step of the
way really to making the film I remember
I remember walking up and down on the
Upper East Side because I'd got there so
early because I didn't want to be late
so I just ended up
wandering around and then I remember
going in I remember talking with Rob and
John I remember thinking this is the
nicest place I've ever been in New York
and then I remember singing and remember
Rob pretty much did some brutal told me
there and then you said what we're going
to do this workshop and we'd love you to
come and do it and then the week of the
workshop I just I don't think I've ever
done something where I felt serene so
immediately
oh I understand who this man is I
understand that he is he is representing
the audience he's he's he's an everyman
who is worried about the things that
I've been worried about in my life when
you're having a baby can I do this is
this even something I'm capable of and
then and then he gets the son to be this
hero at the end and I am and I loved it
and then at the end of the at the end of
the workshop Rob came and found me and I
can remember so vividly I can you
remember what I was putting in my
rucksack at the time and he held my hand
and he said I promise you if we make
this film we will not make it without
you
and there and lots of people say things
like that in this industry and lots of
them mean them but over time it gets
watered down and it dissipates and it
dissipates and for whatever reason it
doesn't happen and I will always be
indebted to Rob for it and be just
overwhelmed by what a phenomenal what a
phenomenal experience the whole thing's
been really hmm and and I guess is
somebody who had a Tony nomination age
12 it is fair to think of you as a
Broadway baby
so did you I mean you were an infant
when this show first premiered but did
you know the show was a sort of part of
your DNA in a way exactly yeah I saw the
Bernadette Peters VHS when I was about
10 I think and um I like many people
before me thought that the first act was
the end of the show and um and then I
remember watching the second act and
being kind of upset that this was
happening to these characters because
they were characters I knew and loved
and
and people I liked and um I remember
even at the time feeling very challenged
by it and sort of grateful and thinking
I should watch this one again when I'm
older and and now of course it's it's
the bit of the piece that is the most
rewarding and that's where all the
thematic resonance really lies for me
and it's really the only reason that it
should even exist is to get to the meat
of that second part of the piece to see
what happens when these characters are
really tested will throw it open to the
audience after this but I just have to
ask Anna because you get to in on the
steps of the palace you get probably my
favorite rhyme and all of Sondheim which
is the stuck with the shoe in a stew and
the goo and you've learned something too
something you never knew what is it like
to actually sing that it's so
extraordinary to hear um it's funny
because that is such a clever rhyme and
and it's so clever that um we talked
about this in the recording studio
because it's almost too clever and even
while her withers with her with her is
not quite as knowing and clever and
because it's so knowing you we decided
to kind of play with the idea that yes
she's singing and we exist in a world
where she doesn't know she's singing you
know she hasn't broken into songs she
isn't in real life she's not speaking in
rhyme um but it was just so clever and
cheeky that we decided that Cinderella
is sort of proud of herself for coming
up with that line and that was you know
because she's proud of herself for
thinking to leave the shoe and finding a
way to avoid making this decision and
then to you know throw that rhyme and on
top of it it's almost like she's kind of
showing off so there was um yeah it was
kind of a playful thing it was great to
be able to wink at it a tiny bit that's
a wonderful answer and it actually makes
her high note at the end of the song
that much more triumphant like look what
I've achieved I've done all these rhymes
and I'm on the steps of the palace
uh okay let's have some questions from
the floor
is there a roving mic reduced wanna
bellow yep there go hi there Tim
shifting from holy moly I've been a song
time obsessive for a long long time
particularly into the woods and so being
an obsessive I kind of thought there was
no chance that you could make fun with
this and not make a mess of it
but you've actually exceeded
expectations and I think of what you've
got here is a modern classic so thank
you for not ruining my favorite thing I
want to know did any of you and are you
brave enough to admit go into this
thinking film versions of musicals tend
not to work this will probably not work
well I can answer that quite singly A's
there is only there is genuinely there
is one reason why it isn't and it's Rob
that's it there is no other reason and
it will embarrass him hugely but is I
don't think anybody will ever I can't
even conceive of how you take a show
that is three hours long and like you
say be loved by so many people
passionately and you cut an hour and you
don't lose a beat of story a beat of
heart a beat of humor and if anything
you go are I don't even know what I've
really missed and yet it holds and I no
one else can take credit for that except
for Rob because it felt like even on the
first day in that workshop in an empty
black room in the Julliard in New York
that here was a director who has lived
with this for a very long time and could
see it on a canvas from such a great
heights that he could see exactly how an
audience are going to react to things
and I can remember I'm saying to me no
one wants to see in a film for ballads
in a row
like it will hold on stage because
you're watching something very different
it's a personal interaction between you
and their performer and they're actually
there and they're doing it on stage it's
just it's depreciating returns every
time we do it and and and he said it's
all about protecting no one is alone
because that's the heartbeat of the
thing and you kind of go oh yeah yeah
sure cool yeah and then you and then
I've watched other musicals since I've
watched movie musicals in the last sort
of year and a half and I've gone are
you're completely right the first ballot
in this movie movie musical knock the
wind out of my sails the second one I
was like oh yes good the third one I'm
like woof the fourth one goes for
nothing and that's not because the
performances aren't right they're
amazing but so to have a director who
can do it and pull it off in the way
that you so it's so wonderful for us to
hear that that's the reason and I don't
think there's anyone else on earth could
do it I genuinely don't know if anyone
else could take this text and make a
film that would work in this manner
truly I wholeheartedly agree I Rob and I
work you know cheek by jowl through
every process of the film and for the
last three years it is a very difficult
balancing act this piece the humor the
emotion the the the the depth of emotion
but getkey the fairytale aspect the
musical aspect it's all it's it's really
difficult and in terms of what James
just said rob understand understood how
to calibrate all those different aspects
and make it a whole and make the tone
work from beginning to end and it was
just it was just breathtaking to watch
him work you know right under the table
thank you a question for James you've
obviously directed with Gary Barlow
you've made a Sondheim's musical what's
next on your wish list in terms of music
solo album his people is it music or
maybe
musically what's on my wish list well I
mean almost for my own enjoyment
like and when I say my own enjoyment I
mean just to record for myself to keep
in my house I've started to think I
should to make a Christmas album because
I I love Christmas music so much I start
listening to it in October and I started
listening to the Buble album I'm very
excited about going to see him at the o2
next week I'm like I really love him
though I still have a started thinking
that maybe I'll just do it on my own no
just like of yourself you know I know so
I might do that you'll never hear it but
man I've got a feeling I might just do
it for my own pleasure
yeah okay we'll do baby is cold outside
I think the guy part you see the guys ha
yeah okay great yes James William great
very source folk tales when we were kids
while you're behind a door anywhere
or do you read me some news I got me a
copy of favorites and all the
best-fitting bits illegally
nice romantic things um I wasn't read
fairytales per se I mean we were read
bedtime stories but they were I I've
mentioned this to a couple people and
only one person so far as known it I
don't know if it's more of an American
thing but the Berenstein bears books and
um those are sort of stories seconds go
but those are sort of stories about you
know little life lessons and and it's
about sort of sharing and forgiveness
and they would particularly read me the
story where Brother Bear does something
mean but sister bear forgives him and I
didn't like being rug that story
um so they would read me these stories
to sort of show me um you know that
family life is complicated and stuff so
it really wasn't the an oversimplified
version of things they tried to read me
books with
um life lessons that I didn't appreciate
I would have prefered fairytale I don't
I always remember finding them a little
bit scary I think that maybe because at
school they started with like Hansel and
Gretel which I think might be the
darkest story you could ever read a
child where a woman locks them in a cage
and then he puts a twig through as his
finger so and uh yeah I haven't read my
son many but I was having this
discussion with someone earlier today
and he said over there you know the I
said I find them a bit scaring it yeah
but they always end so well and I said
yeah but that's that's I think the best
thing about what Stephen Sondheim has
done with this is is say these
fairytales that tell you that I don't
know if it's a particularly healthy
thing to tell children that this notion
of happily ever after will just exists
forever and that's that will be your
life and I think it's a wonderful thing
in this film that in the the song that I
mentioned earlier the no one is alone
there's a moment where they say Anna's
character and my character are talking
to the young children saying Giants can
be good and witches can be right and you
decide what's good and you decide what's
right which I've always sort of taken as
as essentially someone saying which I
think is a really positive message to
say to children to say whatever your
life is and whatever your circumstance
there's some screw ups coming your way
you can't deny it the screw-ups they're
coming for you and in those moments when
you feel like that when life takes those
turns you you're going to feel like
you're completely on your own in the
world you're going to feel completely on
your own and you won't be and you're not
because no one is and and that's made me
think about how I sort of read things to
my children and and the the the impetus
that I will put on certain things
we are though currently reading a book
called bar bars American adventure when
when he gets to Los Angeles we go to my
son amazing fulfill was very impressive
and the main action called
the essence of this stage music college
coaches boxes get arrested possible
change the question to you does it make
you see starring listing music oh yeah
it's all I've ever wanted to do I mean
it's all it's all I've ever well I mean
my whole dream all I wanted at school
was to be in a West End musical and then
I was lucky enough when I was 17 to be
in a musical called Martin guerre which
was um you know I'm not speaking out of
turn to say it was a disaster but um I
was in the chorus and was stood so far
at the back I mean art for a lot of the
show I could touch the back of the wall
that I very well remember very much
having a feeling of going ah so if I
only get to the front I'm gonna have to
go and be on the TV and then come back
but I mean that there are I get a lot
more excited about the prospect of
theory of being in a musical than I do
almost about anything else really like
there are so many shows that I love and
that's not including the new ones that
haven't been written yet but like you
know a dream of mine is to play like Max
Bialystock in the producers is a role
that I've would give my right arm to
play one day
Pseudolus and a funny thing happened on
the way to the forum would would you
know is something I hope I will get the
chance to do one day when I when I saw
Hedwig I just was like oh my god this is
this is the greatest part that's ever
been written there's a musical that
robot she worked on in Broadway which
many people don't know here called a
kiss of the Spider Woman by Kander and
ebb is a role of a guy called Molina
who's a imprisoned drag queen costumier
which I really love
that'll be a turn up wouldn't it
so yes is the answer it's all over I
would I hope so much that I would get to
do any of those - I hope there's some
producers in the house here taking notes
it all sounds very tantalizing yes Rob
film audiences are getting used to the
idea of of movies in which lots of big
characters come together in one film
because comic book movies and things
like the Avengers did that actually have
an impact on why this film came together
now this musical came to the screen now
and also just quickly I mean did you say
did you say to model Johnny Depp's look
after Jack White from the White Stripes
I didn't quite understand that second
part about Johnny Depp and the ways cos
it was just daily looks like he looks
very much like Jack White from the white
sir all right very good very good white
stripes um I'll just answer that quickly
johnny is a real creative force and he
loves to be a part of the creation of
his look that's a big part of what he
does and calling out what our costume
designer and he have worked together for
many many years since Edward
Scissorhands and so he was always
inspired by the wolf of the Tex Avery
cartoons of the 40s if you know those
cartoons the wolf is in a zoot suit and
so that's why we went in that direction
for this version of the wolf the the
license being that it's seen through a
child's eyes so she sees this wolf in
this way so that was that was fun for
him to create and then the first part of
the question was about sort of like the
characters I mean one of the joys of
this piece is this extraordinary
ensemble of actors and characters I mean
there are 19 principals in this film no
ensemble no chorus just that ensemble of
principal actors and you know that's one
of the great joys of this piece and when
we had time which is very rare in a film
to rehearse like a company which we had
that that was one of the joys of this
piece I think just being together and
figuring out what we were going to do
and making mistakes and falling down and
getting up and figuring it out and and
and you know
with a with a movie like this it's very
important that everyone's in the same
film you know and that's one of the
trickiest parts about a large cast you
want to make sure that we're all the
tone is similar we're all working in the
same way and that happened you know I
have to say from the first day of
rehearsal we have this incredible
leaders you know I had James and Anna
and Meryl Streep and Emily Blunt and
Chris Pine everybody they're sort of
leading the charge and and giving
everything they had I mean everybody was
nervous very nervous about it I think we
were all scared because we knew this is
a beloved piece we loved and we wanted
to do it right and do it well so we all
sort of grabbed hands and jumped in
together and did it but that time that
precious time when you create a piece
and rehearsals was really was the
foundation of what this film became hi
guys congratulations on a beautiful
piece of cinema and my question is for
Anna obviously this is a film that
blends two universal magics fairy tales
and music and we've already heard about
your kind of introduction to fairy tales
but I'm curious if you could share with
us how you discovered the magic of music
and what it is that excites you and
makes you enjoy it so much because such
a huge part of your career at the moment
obviously sorry say that last bit again
sorry just how we discovered the magic
of music and and what you continue to
love about it
um I mean that's a hard question that's
like asking my discovery of oxygen water
and shelter um those are all pretty good
I enjoy them um yeah I mean my mother
maintains that the first song I ever
sang was lady in red and I [ __ ] hate
that song so I don't believe Bale my
Christmas out
although not technically a Christmas
song and red is very much a Christmas
color but I mean I think there were a
number of people who reported back to my
mother from school saying Anna want stop
singing that kind of thing but you know
those those memories are like I can't
remember if I remember them or if I just
think that I do because I've been told
about them so many times to be totally
honest this I don't tell this story much
because it sounds sort of fake but I
really was always kind of attached to
the little red part because I saw the
piece so young
and that's more in my vocal range and
being loud and bratty is more in my
wheelhouse than being open and
vulnerable but there was some reason
that I was trying to learn steps of the
palace for fun or something years ago
and I remember that being the first time
that I looked at a piece of music and
thought and really understood or began
to understand the genius of Sondheim
because he writes your performance into
the melody and you have this amazing
opportunity to work with someone and be
elevated by this performance there's
never a part where you're going oh god
okay when the third chorus comes back
around like how should I make that you
know make sure that that has life and
energy you know it's it was like I was
playing with the greatest tennis partner
in the world and it made it really
difficult but it made me do my best work
so actually on the steps of the palace
because it see it sounds fake it sounds
like I'm kidding um it was one of the
first pieces that made me understand
what music can do for you emotionally
yes
thank you I grew up watching a lot of
Disney fairy Todd adaptations and I
never really bonded with Cinderella just
few Anna cuz you've really made me love
Cinderella now what for you what for you
drew you to the role and what makes us
so appealing now um I mean first of all
I'd say it's on time as the person who
drew to this Cinderella because I'm
playing a very very different Cinderella
I'm not sure that I'd be able to achieve
that if it would you know just the first
half of the piece even um I think that
seeing what we think of as a kind of two
dimensional sort of she sort of exists
as a plot device in a lot of iterations
and to see the person that she becomes
when she's faced with something much
greater than herself and the decisions
that she makes in those moments is a is
much more interesting than even than her
personal journey because once her
personal journey is done and I mean and
Sondheim does put so much neurotic
energy into her that she's a lot more
fun to hang out with the most
Cinderella's I think um but to see the
the person that she becomes in the face
of great tragedy is what makes her
appealing that's great for his neurotic
energy for so much of Sondheim and it's
really true we've got room time for
about one more question there ago John
said this he handbook very 15 evening I
was surprised that you like because he
was so busy and together any any so when
you surprised by half of you they
adopted took the project on and also
waiting it six I don't think I was
surprised because we rob and I had both
worked with them prior on a film of
Pirates of the Caribbean and we had the
greatest relationship with them
and we had a great trust with them and
they knew that we would we would treat
this with integrity and with the respect
you know when a studio gives you the
money you take it and you you do
everything you can to make it work in
terms of I don't know it is it is an odd
fit for what you think of as the old
traditional Disney but I think they were
ready at this point to make that step
into the 21st century with characters
that were very near and dear to them so
and and they trusted Rob implicitly so
why not boldly take that step as Walt
did years and years ago with his classic
now fairy tales to make a new you know
journey into a new kind of unknown area
where where they had not you know they
had not gone before so I was thrilled
that they would take that they were
excited as well so it was a nice journey
for all of us well I think that trust
that John talks about has been amply
repaid and on that note we have to wrap
this up I'm afraid but thank you all for
coming and many thanks to Anna Rob James
and John
you